[Music]
you see the kim kardashian interview i
just saw the clip of her you need to get
up and work so what else did she say um
i don't know she said this is like the
best podcast ever
listen to tmg
yeah all the time
yeah
bonus episodes they get we're more
personal and you know they connect with
their problems you talk about the dark
thoughts they have and their addiction
yes exactly way better than the bonus
yeah
and people don't work hard enough by the
way let it rip yeah play something get
your [ __ ] ass up and work get your
[ __ ] ass up
from the start we decided that we always
wanted to be really open and honest to
who we are and that's why we love the
tmg bonus
because they're always talking about
diarrhea
so why positive people were slamming her
were they slamming her i love that they
were you know they were dunking on her
because what she had her career like
handed to her i guess
can you really say that though not that
i'm like being like an apologist i'm
just playing devil's advocate a little
yeah i mean i would probably think that
they do work hard like she did have to
do those episodes and all that [ __ ] yeah
hot take man yeah
we're actually with the kardashians
honestly and then we spent last episode
roasting their house for [ __ ]
but honestly
they deserve it they're all [ __ ] but
they definitely work i guess i don't
know
know actually that was one of the things
that uh watching episode three of genius
seeing him at his at the ranch i don't
know like just like what is that room
i've i've known what the [ __ ] is going
on i know two people in that room i know
two people that have been there and what
did they say he's like that all the time
yeah everyone everyone says
feels like sorry what's going on in his
head yeah it's actually going on in real
life literally
so one of my friends
went there because he was doing
something with the company i don't want
to [ __ ] say but he said it was the
most psycho thing ever he like walked in
and he's like there's like a pod of like
architects working on like some building
design and then there's this person over
here and he's just like moving through
what looks like it's just [ __ ] chaos
um i think he sat around for a while
to like pitch something for him they
just didn't end up doing it because he
was just caught up doing whatever and
they left and the other person i know
worked on
jesus is king i think he's actually
he's the mix engineer that did my ep
like he worked on like a couple tracks
for jesus cam thing or whatever and
anytime he's worked with kanye they
leave out field recorders like all
around the room because kanye might just
sit down and just start like humming
some [ __ ]
and then
that's it they'll be like i had an idea
he sits down and he just like gives out
like some melody and he might just like
do some nonsensical freestyle i was like
you got that cool he leaves
and it's up to him and like three
producers and a writer to craft the
whole concept wow then he comes back and
he's like nah take that [ __ ] out put
this in i like that he gave me a window
into like his production process he was
showing us some of the printed mixes
and
they're like the specificity on the
mixes are so crazy like he'll have one
version of a song where they worked on
it
in i don't know
tahiti or something and he flew out some
bassist from somewhere
and he likes the bass line how that was
played from that version
so he'll be like uh can you get the bass
line from the version that we did in
tahiti and put it on the one we did at
the ranch
it's like well we have like nine
versions that we did at the ranch and
then he just sort of expects you to kind
of figure it out and so yeah
like both of them said working in that
environment feels
just maddening but they're they're
working like out in the open and there's
a photo shoot going on for a fashion
line over here doing pottery over here
like a gospel choir over here yeah and
it's just like they're all in one giant
barn basically and it just felt like it
almost felt like watching one of channel
five's videos yeah watch
his videos how he's people from
different videos will just show up yeah
you know what i'm saying it's like you
know he's giving some crazy rant about
abortion and then justin bieber is just
sitting there yeah and then the lady
that he met to do the the lady that
makes those bowls in san francisco like
shows up i don't know where it's like
what the [ __ ] is happening yeah all
right what do you think about episode
three i thought it was pretty depressing
i don't know it just it doesn't really
end on like a real positive note it kind
of ends with cootie being like you know
happy this all worked out but like he's
really fighting his demons and i really
hope that he gets so he's okay like all
those weird manic rants he would go on
at the end like to other people and cody
would just kind of shut off the camera
because he's like i know where this is
going the way he cut that and like that
sound that he would keep using like for
like cutting film and when he and any
time he used that to cut off kanye's
rants i don't know that [ __ ] made me
feel like [ __ ] it
for two years
yeah just you got the feeling yeah it's
weird like seeing his disease progress
over the three episodes and over you
know whatever it's been 20 30 years
because in the beginning it's not like
that you know and then i guess you know
maybe it comes with more notoriety and
stuff like that but all that is like a
catalyst and
speeding up whatever sort of mental
disease you have not even to like make
it about this but in some ways dude um i
think like when i made find that link i
look back at that now i'm like i 100
feel like that was
why no it was like mania i like woke up
one day and i was like this could be a
thing watching back a dude going through
it and then people around him
just needing to kind of
go through the motion because they're
like close to him and i think that's the
part where people don't understand like
how difficult it is to tell someone like
you have to come off this idea it's like
or you need to chill out it's like they
just don't get it it's not that i'm on
his level or anything like that it's
just more like that i think that was the
depressing part for me personally was
one that kind of self-reflection where
you know in the moment kanye probably
like really believes these ideas that he
has and like they're so earnest and real
like in his mind i think the other part
actually that
cody did a great job of highlighting is
like a very human thing which is like
just
being distant from a friend who you used
to be close with it's like a really
rudimentary thing but i thought that
theme through the whole three episodes
i think like some people maybe had
criticism of the third episode where
they're like well what the [ __ ] is this
episode you didn't even cover
anything in depth of that whole period
where he kind of like went [ __ ]
parabolic like with his career i kind of
think that's the really depressing part
is that his really close friend who is
there for all that [ __ ] prior just a
ghost for that second half yeah i mean
it was like the whole thing was from
cootie's perspective so it kind of makes
sense no yeah yeah yeah and plus we all
know that part of the story at least the
people that are our age do it's like
that's when we started being fans of him
right when he started blowing up
so it's like we know we've seen all the
media and everything that that scene
where he like
walks up to kanye for the life is pablo
like listening party yeah and there's
that weird like oh what's up man it's
just like ah no i hate that ow because
it's also like the the working
relationship mm-hmm yeah we don't know
if he got paid right in the beginning
connie had no money yeah did he just do
all that did he just do it all like give
up his entire life
for kanye just like ghost them sort of
for him to still try to get back into it
because he still believes there's a
relationship there or like he they're
still homies mm-hmm and for that awkward
interaction to happen this is rough
maybe you know we don't know the full
details but i mean he got to come out
with everything so more than focusing on
like who kanye is or whatever i think
just that the fact that it's from
cootie's perspective and just that whole
experience of like this was my really
close friend i don't know it's like
weird he went from this guy who was like
you know pretty like just would could
hold a conversation normally and all
that stuff and all those like there's
nothing i think he was definitely
quirky he was definitely quirky i agree
but that's what it seemed like it was in
the beginning and then you kind of see
it and then he was like the guy that
would say weird things sometimes in the
media i was just thinking of the clip
where he kept calling cootie chike that
is so [ __ ] yeah that's who i work with
and that's like our boy but like that's
literally not me i know ugh that made me
cringe so hard that moment where cooties
like you call me chiki again one more
time i know
no
rough ending